[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace 7 meses que estoy haciendo dieta
estoy cansada tengo muy poca energía
no puedo concentrarme en otra cosa que
no sea mirar el en el espejo
los resultados que espero no llegan sigo
hago todo todo todo lo que siempre no
llega
cuando me voy a ver bien cuando voy a
volver a sonreír
no no no no qué vergüenza ponerme al
lado de las chicas
y ya está
inventos invento que me pasó algo que
estoy enferma y no voy no quiero no
puedo ir así no quiero que me vean
de qué están hechos estos ladrillos
de qué están hechos estos muros que nos
limitan
porque nos sentimos protegidos atrás de
estas paredes que nos asfixian en china
las mujeres eran consideradas bellas
según el tamaño de su piel desde los 5
años usaban zapatos de hasta 7
centímetros para evitar que les crezca
el pie
en japón muchas personas se pegan los
párpados o incluso se operan para tener
los ojos más grandes si quieren tener
los ojos redondos porque es una
tendencia aspiracional en el oriente
muchos de nosotros estaremos pensando
que es una locura que haya personas que
este auto provoquen malformaciones en
los pies se peguen los ojos para poder
pertenecer y encajar en el estereotipo
de belleza
claro verlo de lejos es muy simple ahora
qué pasa en nuestra cultura
eso parece menos doloroso no
las apariencias engañan a los pasamos
era caliente para arrancarnos los pelos
nos sometemos a todo tipo de cirugía
tobillos quijadas costillas y posiciones
esta me la note porque ni siquiera me la
podía aprender de memoria gluteoplastia
no me imagino lo que debe doler
inhalamos el olor del veneno del alisado
soportamos kilos y kilos de pesas para
ganar más masa musculares e incluso
dejamos de comer forzamos nuestra
naturaleza en pos de una ficción que nos
oprime nos acostumbramos a una
incomodidad que no elegimos de manera
consciente es sorprendente todo lo que
estamos dispuestos de hacer para encajar
en el estereotipo como podemos ver la
idea de belleza va cambiando según la
época el país donde estemos parados esto
quiere decir que lejos de ser una
naturaleza la idea de belleza es una
construcción social y hoy en día esta
construcción no deja terreno sin
conquistar
mirando historias de instagram me alarmó
la cantidad de publicidades a la que
estamos expuestos y los mensajes que
transmiten veamos juntos estas tres
obras de arte
es el hogar de una aplicación que te
invita a que lo instales en tu celular
para editar tus fotos y tener más likes
un centro de estética transmitiendo que
si cambiamos una parte de nuestro cuerpo
vamos a hacer otras personas
esto directamente es todo lo que está
mal un objeto representando el cuerpo de
una nena que la está pasando mal por no
tener suficientes tetas el centro médico
dando la solución y encima en 24 cuotas
la publicidad una industria que lucra
con nuestras inseguridades empresa
constructora de ladrillos externos pero
de peso interno que se reproduce a una
velocidad imparable esta construcción va
tan rápido que no nos damos ni cuenta
ahora somos solo simples receptores de
estos mensajes que estamos haciendo
cuando aceptamos estos ladrillos sin
cuestionarlos reproducimos esta forma de
mirar y de ser mirados un copy-paste
humano de gustos intereses objetivos
cuerpos
y esa malla no estoy muy gorda y no
debería ponerse cosas apretadas no le da
el cuerpo para eso
odio mi papá
seria tan feliz con 7 kilos menos el
linda de cara yo te digo que sea el gaza
para mí la rompe todas estas frases son
parte de lo que en el mundo se conoce
como factor está comprobado que miras
más uno escucha o repite frases
quejándose del cuerpo de uno o
criticando el cuerpo de los demás mayor
insatisfacción corporal siente con cada
uno de sus comentarios
inconscientemente sume mis ladrillos a
la construcción del estereotipo de
belleza
estos ladrillos
que no solo se sumaron a mi muralla sino
que también edificaron la muralla de los
demás cada uno de nosotros es influencer
de su entorno lo que decimos impacta en
nuestro entorno
las relaciones sociales influyen en la
representación que tenemos sobre
nosotros mismos es hora de estar atentos
y elegir qué mensaje queremos comunicar
este ladrillo lo tituló mi fiesta de
egresados
cuando tenía 17 años me di la cabeza
contra la pared fuerte me pasé un año
entero entre dietas milagrosas tips de
retención de líquidos ayunos prolongados
exceso de ejercicio físico etiquetas y
calorías todo por la obsesión colectiva
de entrar en un disfraz
en este
seis horas metiendo panza les aseguro
que no respiraba pero pertenecía había
que hacer todo cueste lo que cueste
pasó la fiesta y justo cuando empezaba a
relajarme apareció otra misión había que
llegar al verano
esta carrera por el cuerpo no tenía
punto de llegada
desapareció un ladrillo pero de
pestañear sabían otros
y ese año de obsesiones tuvo sus
consecuencias al terminar el secundario
tres compañeras empezaron tratamiento
por desórdenes alimenticios
en ese momento me llamó tanto la
atención que empecé a buscar información
y lo que creía que sólo pasaba en mi
colegio no era un caso aislado
ese golpe me despertó
cuando uno despierta empieza a ver todo
distinto todo lo que hasta ese momento
tenía naturalizado me empezaba a hacer
ruido salí a la noche por personas que
eran discriminadas de las puertas de
boliche por el aspecto físico verme me
denigrantes escuchar cientos y cientos
de comentarios acerca del cuerpo de los
demás de los demás empecé a sentir que
algo tenía que hacer una madrugada no
podía dormir y entre insomnio e
inspiración hace poco más de un año
decidí crear bellamente una cuenta de
instagram donde empezaba a exponer eso
que sentía a las pocas horas que
publique un texto hablando de la
cantidad de cosas que estamos dispuestos
dejar de hacer por miedo a la exposición
empezaron a llegar mensajes
tapen los espejos de mi casa porque no
quiero verme de las piernas marina
me gritaron tanto gordo de chico que hoy
a la hora de tener una relación sexual
tiemblo no puedo sacarme la ropa hwan
no voy más a comprarme ropa las últimas
veces es 'la y llorando por no encontrar
prendas en mi taller josefina esos tres
mensajes no me los voy a olvidar más
cada historia que llegaba pedía a gritos
un cambio de paradigma
desarmando mi muralla descubrí que con
esa mente podía colaborar en la
deconstrucción de otras
empecé a estudiar psicología no podía
quedarme mirando la pantalla del
celulares quería tener un marco teórico
arranque a formar parte del equipo de
prevención en trastornos en la conducta
alimentaria y encontré la manera de
hacer un puente de una y de una cuenta
de instagram nació un proyecto social
enfocado en la prevención bellamente se
convirtió en un espacio de diálogo real
y virtual donde repensamos la idea
hegemónica de belleza promoviendo la
autoaceptación una comunidad de más de
60.000 personas ya no estoy sola con mis
pensamientos ahora somos una red de
personas redefiniendo el concepto de
belleza empezamos a poner el cuerpo el
proyecto tomó vida propia salió a la
calle entró en las casas en las empresas
en los shoppings hasta incluso en las
aulas donde ambos talleres para docentes
en todas las provincias del país para
que puedan trabajar sobre la autoestima
y la imagen corporal
desde bellamente activamos a favor de
una sociedad más justa e inclusiva pero
sabemos que empoderar a las personas es
el primer paso para dar un verdadero
salto necesitamos el compromiso de todos
y cuando digo todos es todos por eso
estamos desarrollando una certificación
para comprometer a las marcas las
agencias los medios de comunicación a
que tomen conciencia del impacto mental
y emocional que tienen sus mensajes de
esta forma poder prevenir en un futuro
los efectos nocivos que hasta hoy
producen en la sociedad
no se puede vender a cualquier costo no
hay rentabilidad que justifique lo
perjudicar a un otro
[Aplausos]
sueño con el día en el que fabricar una
prenda en talle único sea recordado como
de otra época sueño en el día en el que
hagan una revista y pueda leer una nota
que se hable más de personas y menos de
cuerpos es hora de que las marcas y los
medios entiendan la responsabilidad que
tienen por su influencia en la sociedad
son una gran herramienta de
transformación
cambiar horas de auto tortura despejo
horas de críticas por horas de
investigación de activismo hizo que el
tiempo cobre otro sentido
no hay obstáculos cuando se baja el
volumen de las opiniones de afuera y se
empieza a escuchar y seguir la voz
propia
este proyecto transforma la vida de
otros pero sigo asombrada del antes y el
después que generó en mí ninguna dieta
pudo darme eso
hoy
los invito a todos ustedes a que elijan
desde su lugar cómo pueden hacer para
que este ladrillo no se siga sumando a
la muralla que tanto nos limita gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]